but i was saying since michael holly
likes to be right
um we brought on somebody who's going to
co-sign him i think we actually showed
you a headline from dead spin earlier
that the nfl uh needs a bubble so
the floor is yours my friend
i mean like how else if i get that they
did all of this because
they're thinking down the line and they
want their money maker the super bowl to
happen
but we have where we week four week five
because i've lost all track of time but
if we're going to make
to six seven or eight how if we're
rescheduling games already and swapping
out teams bye week and if the biggest
game so far of the year we're just going
to get cam versus mahomes and we know
how this patriots chiefs afc matchup
every year has led to some very huge
game in terms of ratings just in terms
of impact it'll have on the postseason
if that's getting knocked to a monday
night and cam's not in it like what are
we going to do
for the rest of the year if they can't
even get their sexiest games on air with
the players that they need for this to
keep going so at some point they're
going to have to figure out some type of
system because this is just a game where
big sweaty dudes tackle each other for
60 minutes and i don't know how used to
saying sustain that in a pandemic when
we're expecting the nfl to handle this
property when the nfl doesn't handle
anything properly
yeah it's a good point and i agree with
you and i don't know the answer to this
maybe we can figure this out together
how will that bubble work
like what's that bubble look like in
your estimation
now i'm smart but i'm like not that
smart to figure out but i know that i'm
smart enough to call dr fauci and some
healthcare professionals because if you
just take a peek ahead to college
basketball they're about to figure out
some type of bubble system just because
the ncaa can't go two years without
their biggest money maker in the march
madness tournament so we're they're they
started the season's going to start on
december 1st they're going to figure
this out the nfl had the most league
time of any sports league this pandemic
kicked off in march like they had more
time than anybody else to get this
together and they're still fumbling you
know to put in a little play on words
but
you got to get team somewhere north
dakota south dakota i don't care where
you go
and get everybody in an isolated area in
order to play football because if we're
still trying to allow fans in and fly
and stay in hotels and go to restaurant
like you're just putting
a huge amount of people at risk outside
of those that need to actually play
football
yo i'm sorry man
my mind's all over the place can we take
a wide shot of karen's crib real quick
because like yo man like yo yo your
house is even decorated like a bachelor
like you got incense burning somewhere
in your house right now don't
look man
you're telling too much right now i'm
getting uncomfortable like look
you're snitching
as michael said earlier um
the decor
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports